und herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren episode
das herunter gefallen
wir befinden uns hier schon im spiel ihr
seht ich bin level 1 weil diese nicht
gerade erst raus gekommen ist und der
arzt natürlich auch schönen titel
eingeblendet gesehen wir spielen heute
nicht normal fortnight sondern mit dem
eye tracker also ihr seht wo
habe ich grade auf die brüste geschaut
[Musik]
ja das ist halt das problem an diesem
treffer ihr seht also heute ganz genau
wo ich hinschaue und als allererstes
kann ich euch noch mal eben hier was
sagen und zwar klickt mal hier oben auf
itemshop falls sie selber fordert spielt
und dann hier unten bei unterstütze
einen vetter will ich mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr dort luca eingeben würde dann
steht hier oben rechts unterstützt der
creator luca und immer wenn ihr euch was
bei ford kaufte bekomme ich ein wenig
von dem geld ab was an epic games geht
also ihr zahlt keinen cent mehr und
könnte mich quasi kostenlos unterstützen
wir klicken jetzt aber erst mal hier auf
spielen sieht das ganze jetzt aus wenn
wir halt in dem sinn bisher noch nicht
richtig in game sondern erst gerade noch
in der lobby er mir sieht ganz genau wo
ich hier wirklich die ganze zeit
hinschauen das heißt ich kann jetzt
sagen ich gucke auf den po und dann
schaue ich auf den hof und vielleicht
ist es ja ganz interessant dass hier mal
seht wo so richtige fortnight profis wie
ich überhaupt ihre augen hinschauen ob
mein gott es geht los ich dachte mir
halt hey ich bin wirklich ein erfahrener
fortnight spieler im spiel das spiel
schon echt sehr lange spielzeit wirklich
sehr lang und leben sprechen bin ich
auch wirklich sehr gut ich dachte es ist
vielleicht cool dass ihnen mal sehen wo
ich überhaupt hinschauen mein gott das
sind hier die neuen sachen ich würde
sagen wir gehen mal als erstes an die
steps in dieser runde dann gehen wir
gleich noch in diese neue lagune ach
guck mal da ist jetzt sogar somit metern
und so springt ja jetzt mal raus und
runter geht die kg ich habe auch wieder
den unauffälligsten skin aller zeiten
genommen hier und schauen wir uns
nochmal diesen neuen ort sunny steps
jahr nicht wollte eigentlich schon vor
einigen tagen mein video zur these
nature raushauen allerdings hatte ich
leider magen darm und habe eigentlich
den ganzen tag nur gekotzt und gekackt
bitteschön für diese info an konnte ich
leider noch kein video aufnehmen ich
kenne mich auch dementsprechend noch
überhaupt nicht in dieser season hier
aus und weiß überhaupt nicht wie sie 9
das hat auf jeden fall viel sind ergeben
diese treppe abzubauen luca
gab es schon immer vögeln fortnight ich
den profi brauche ich denn jetzt fall
schaden bekommen
oh mein gott ich sage oh mein gott du
glaubst du mein gott
a
habe ich noch gut schaden gegeben ja
war spielen
ist das neue runde neues glück freunde
wir bewegen uns diesmal dorthin das ist
diese neue lagune das ist ja auch sie
sollen dingen wo man drauf springen kann
man dann katapultiert das ein hoch ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was es mir
bringt dass dieser antrag jetzt mit
dabei ist und was es euch bringt das mit
dabei ist aber ich dachte mir hey
vielleicht ist es wirklich wie gesagt
ganz cool es immer bei dem profi seht wo
ich hinschaue während die spiele langsam
reichts luca und sag mal diesen neuen
ort hier an das ist also diese lucky
lady
lay
geisterschiff auch schon in der hälfte
durch ich dachte wirklich dass mit
dieser season jetzt mit dazu kommt dass
man im wasser endlich auch schwimmen
kann bisher ist hat was er ja immer
irgendwie irre pinkl hoch
ich sehe schon wieder die ganzen
kommentare von wegen hey luca warum
spielst du nicht mit kopfhörern eheleute
echte profis braucht keine kopfhörer
natürlich kann man mit kopfhörern besser
hören helfen wo kommen die gegner aber
bei mir ist es halt so
ich habe keine gegner dubai statt
ja ich wollte mich auf die treppe
springen ja nie aber meine ganze
bescheidenheit hierbei seite ich finde
die neue season echt ganz nah das ist
jetzt das zweite oder dritte mal dass
ich jetzt überhaupt eine runde spieler
aber ich finde dieses ganze piraten
dingen als ich finde ich sehr sehr sehr
sehr cool aber ich mag auch allgemein
piraten ja ich bin auch an karneval mal
als pirat gegangen
das liebe ich ja eher an fortnight und
an den web making menschen dort
matchmaking menschen genau wie geben
sich immer so unfassbar viel mühe und
sind so detailverliebt ich mein ich
das mal an das hängt sogar piraten
fischernetzen hier sagen wir bewegen uns
jetzt mal so langsam ein bisschen in die
zone die ist nämlich jetzt schon wieder
gewandert was haben wir denn auch ein
eiswagen der tage anscheinend ein
kleinunfall dass jetzt diese atome
totentempel da oben glaubt aber
jetzt muss ich
ab heiliger bimbam
was machst du meintest du
nein macht doch keinen fall jetzt bin
ich der bürger vor
das war ja und findet mich aber rasch 7
kills alter so will habe ich meiner
ganzen karriere doch nicht gemacht aber
gute freunde eine neue runde neues glück
ich würde sagen wir springen diesmal
direkt in den vulkan rein ich weiß nicht
ob das eine gute idee ist aber wir
können sie einfach mal ausprobieren ich
mache mir jetzt schon einen fallschirm
auf und wenn man in den vokalen
reinschaut sieht man schon da drin ist
lava um ein god what the [ __ ] hätte ich
gar nicht gedacht dass man hier einfügen
kann ich dass ich sterbe tiere auch
okay
ach da kann ich dann rüber fliegen
ach so ja dann gehen wir jetzt mal
direkt hier zu den leuten und hauen hier
ja noch nicht wissen neue runde neues
glück freunde wir gehen wieder direkt in
den vulkan rein ich muss aber ganz
ehrlich sagen dass ich dieses diesen aid
bisher wirklich als die geilste diesen
sehe ich weiß bin kein fordert kanal
meine meinung interessiert
wahrscheinlich kein schwein aber für
mich ist es eine sehr sehr geiles diesen
beamten diesmal nicht direkt in diesem
quartal sondern hier vorne
ist aber wer baut sich denn ein haus
direkt an einen vulkan aber auch auf
thema zurückzukommen ich finde dieses
diesen wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr geil
weil ich meine ich hab auch geil
gefunden als damals dass sie dazu kam
und auch der schnee hier hinten aber
jetzt halt mit piraten dings und diesen
neuen bäumen und
das ist dass ich hätte nur wirklich sehr
sehr sehr sehr gern irgendwann demnächst
in diesen neun oder so vielleicht hier
so ein areal wo einfach nur wasser ist
wo man aber nicht wenn man drauf felt
stirbt so wie am rande der map sondern
dass man da halt wirklich schwimmen kann
und so weiter und so fort und dann
vielleicht mit boten rumfahren et cetera
pp wir sind alle kisten schon gelüftet
das heißt irgendwo hier ist ein typ und
der ist da hinten
ich bin
ja unfair ist ja auch gamer
gehen wir denn hin wie jedes mal
komplett an rand der map hier achter von
inseln hallo das ist so ein bisschen so
wie wenn das hier ist hogwarts und hier
wohnen hält versteht ihr was ich meine
na das hier ist das allerletzte hause am
arsch der welt ich glaube ich kann mich
keiner stören hallo
kann ich reinig kopf mal okay ja ich bin
so stark weil meinem klopfen backe das
ganze haus das sieht so aus wie in der
schweiz oder in süddeutschland oder so
das ding ist also ich kann es natürlich
nicht beurteilen weil ich selber nicht
so häufig fordert spiele aber an alle
unter euch die wirkliche regelmäßig oder
täglich sogar vorn mitspielen ist hilton
tower sound- also landen noch leute
enthüllte towers war früher war sehr
solide non-plus-ultra ort so hab die
ganzen sachen aber irgendwie habe ich
das gefühl dass mittlerweile diese neuen
orte gegen den sus hinzugefügt werden
halt viel interessanter sind also meines
erachtens nach ist hilton tower wirklich
komplett leer gefegt irgendwie in
letzter zeit bringen hier mal eine falle
an
weil hier wird auch save jemand
herlaufen und zum glück sieht die falle
dann auch niemand und das ist diese tanz
bomben
kommt nochmal
[Musik]
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz sagen zum
support creator coach da einige von
meinen zuschauern sich gefragt haben hey
luca wieso meinst du man kann dich
kostenlos mit etwas supporten aber dann
bekommst du trotzdem geld dafür da geht
es einfach darum dass wenn ihr bei
fortnight euch irgendwas kauft mit
viborg sei es jetzt einen skin für 800
wie bugs oder so dann von diesen 800 wie
wachsen hier so oder so zahlen würde
dann epic games gibt epic games mir was
ab so provisions technisch aber für euch
entsteht dabei quasi kein mehr ins geld
was ihr zahlen müsst also das in einem
ganz kurz zum thema support creator lka
unterstütze einen creator kommt hierbei
fortnight da mich dass einige gefragt
hatten und ich weiß ich bin ein
regelmäßiger fordert spieler und ich bin
auch nicht sonderlich gut in diesem
spiel ich meine ich bin eigentlich der
beste aber vielleicht doch nicht der
allerbeste deswegen will ich euch
natürlich auch nicht böse wenn ihr den
ford code von irgendeinem anderen stream
annimmt oder von einem anderen gamer
oder dann tief in georgia keine ahnung
was ist natürlich ein gutes recht da
selbst entscheiden zu dürfen
wer lässt denn eine sniper mit einem
schluss liegen aber ich brauche nicht
mehr als ein schuss also ich bin
natürlich böse wenn ihr den vortritt
supportact von einem anderen gamer
nehmen wie gesagt ich bin ich der
allerbeste fordert spieler allerdings
wollte ich ja demnächst auch mit strings
anfangen auftritt und da werde ich auf
jeden fall so ein fortnight learning
prozess durchlaufen und werde mir das
spiel selbst mit freunden dann im stream
besser bei bringen und dadurch halt auch
spielpraxis sammeln also das ist auf
jeden fall mein ziel so ein bisschen
aber ich hab mir gerade übrigens vom
turm gebaut und mich in dieses geschütz
gesetzt und jetzt kann ich ein paar
gegner ab
an der stelle möchte das heutige videos
auf werden in meiner lieben freund ich
habe mir einfach gedacht hey ich hab
diesen eye tracker jedoch an meinem
bildschirm kleben und ich wollte immer
wieder fordert hochladen warum bin ich
das ganze nicht einfach also wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen
hoch da nutzt gerne luca als support
creator colt und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]